hey guys it's Riley here and with
fantastic beasts and crimes of Grindle
all coming in theaters this weekend
we decided to look at the connections
from the fantastic Beast franchise and
the Harry Potter saga I decided you see
fantastic beasts and where to find them
and its upcoming sequel the crimes of
Grimm to vault might at first glance
look like nothing more than a prequel or
to some an obvious cash grab on WB's
part to milk the Harry Potter franchise
for all it's worth but upon a third
viewing of fantastic beasts as well as a
thorough investigation into the
marketing campaign of crimes of Grenda
vault the new series reveals a deeper
connection to the Harry Potter franchise
than previously thought sure the
fantastic beasts movies are set in the
same universe but it's a different type
of story at first we only thought the
movie was about well fantastic beasts
but for keen-eyed viewers who noticed a
few nods to the Harry Potter movies the
new series really does act as a true
prequel one that actually flushes out
one of the best storylines that ended
the saga of Harry Potter that Deathly
Hallows
for these new fantastic beasts movies
aren't really a cash grab on WB's parts
though it's a comprehensive story penned
by the great JK Rowling that adds in
additional layers of story on the
deathly hallows themselves great story
needs great characters and plotting and
I can only imagine that these new story
threads being introduced into fantastic
beasts will only enhance our viewing
experience later down the line when we
revisit the Harry Potter movies it
appears Rowling has created her own
universe or saga of films both in scope
and in story and they rivaled that of
the MCU DC in star wars universes
knowing more about the Deathly Hallows
brings more depth and character to Harry
Potter and vice versa so let's do it
let's look at all those connections
here's how fantastic piece connects to
the Deathly Hallows story and Harry
Potter the most simple connection comes
with its two main characters of course
Harry Potter is about a young wizard who
must fight against the forces of
darkness fantastic beasts is about Newt
Scamander also a bright young wizard who
at first was just collecting fantastic
beasts but as soon roped into a fight
against the forces of darkness their
stories seemed a mirror one another at
least on the surface but whereas Harry
Potter's foil was Lord Voldemort newts
foil was revealed to be Gellert
Grindelwald grin devold who proceeds
Voldemort is the most vicious Dark
Wizard of their time the two have a lot
of connections to each other that has
been established in Harry Potter and in
the Deathly Hallows Part 1 and it is
this storyline that connects the two
franchises and appears to be the
storyline they will expand in the crimes
of Grendel vault for you see it was set
up albeit briefly in the first fantastic
beasts movie in which we meet Percival
graves played by Colin Farrell who seems
to be on the hunt for an obscurus or the
manifestation of the repressed energy of
a magical child Graves had a brief
encounter with credence played by Ezra
Miller who will be reprising his role in
the latest movie in they're seen
together graves handsome and necklace a
pendant with a triangle with a circle
and straight line layered in the middle
in other words the Deathly Hallows
we know that Harry wasn't the first
wizard to encounter the immortality
legend behind that symbol and given what
we later learned about Percival graves
true identity dun dun dun it's Johnny
Depp's grin to volt it makes sense that
he carries that necklace with them this
is but a clever visual tie between the
end of one story and the beginning of
another another obvious but obscure
connection comes by the way of the year
in which the first fantastic beast is
set you see the prequel was set in the
Jazz Age of 1926 which isn't really a
date that holds significance for Harry
Potter fans but for those well versed in
their Hogwarts history probably picked
up on the fact that Tom Riddle aka
Voldemort was also born in 1926 while
that could be a coincidence it's also
likely that Voldemort himself could
appear in later fantastic beast movies
cementing even more of a connection to
the Deathly Hallows and the Harry Potter
movies the connection goes even deeper
with Gellert Grindelwald and Albus
Dumbledore yes that Dumbledore played
here by Jude Law Grindelwald was a
student at durmstrang Institute and was
later expelled for twisted dark
experiments and a near fatal attack on
his fellow students later he fostered a
friendship with a young Dumbledore
making plans to find the Deathly Hallows
in order to lead a Wizarding revolution
that was to end the International
statute of secrecy which would create a
pecking order so to speak between
wizards and muggles their partnership
ultimately fell apart after the two were
involved
a three-way duel which included
Dumbledore's brother Aberforth that
resulted in the death of his sister
Ariana and grit a vault then left
Britain but not before stealing the
Elder Wand from my coup Gor Gurevich
with the other one on person grinned a
vault proceeded to start the revolution
he and Dumbledore had planned you can
even see the elder one in Grindelwald
possession and a lot of the trailers for
fantastic beasts this particular
connection was in front of her very eyes
the entire time it's proving that JK
Rowling truly knows her story having
laid out the connections between the two
franchises as part of some backstory and
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
Part 1 perusing the official wiki page
of the Harry Potter franchise
we learned that grinned a vault threw
himself into his research on the Deathly
Hallows uncovering the location of the
Elder Wand and then it was learned that
the renowned wand maker Grigorovich was
in possession of the wand and was trying
to duplicate its properties and as seen
in some of the flashes in Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows Part one grinned
a vault broke into Grigorovich his
workshop and stole the wand thereby
becoming its new master
this leads Voldemort searching for the
whereabouts of the wand leading him to
Grigorovich who confesses it was Grint a
vault who stole the wand
Voldemort then finds Grindelwald who
reveals that of course Dumbledore had it
further cementing the connection comes
with a surprise treat and one of the
final trailers of the crimes of dread a
vault and which has revealed that the
loyal pet of Voldemort Nagini
one of the final Horcruxes in Deathly
Hallows was actually once a human and is
now slated to appear in the crimes a
grin devil Claudia Kim's previously
unknown character is actually a witch
named Nagini
and she has the ability to turn into
well surprised a snake this furthers the
connection to Harry Potter and moreover
Voldemort almost maybe guarantying will
see a future Voldemort aka Tom Riddle
in a future movie in the fantastic
beasts franchise so with a necklace at
the Deathly Hallows the Elder Wand the
year of 1926 in which Tom Riddle is born
Dumbledore and finally Nagini fantastic
beasts crimes of Grindelwald is proving
to reveal little details of the Deathly
Hallows which serve as the through-line
in the Harry Potter movies ensure these
connections are about a few examples
there are many other connections as well
both a name recognition charms spells
and of course in Hogwarts which will be
making an appearance
in the next movie but before we go some
food for thought where is the cloak of
invisibility and the Sorcerer's Stone
with the Elder Wand now being the
biggest connection could future
fantastic beast movies fill in these
blanks if crimes of Grint of all proves
to be a box-office hit then I'm sure
we'll see more deathly hallow
connections later on down the line but
what did I miss there's a lot out there
that I might not have spoken about so
are there more Harry Potter connections
and fantastic beasts and its own sequel
the crimes of grin 2 vol where are my
Potterheads heidi drop in your own
theories and thoughts and make sure you
share this video get everyone at home to
play along and if you even want more
fantastic piece action you can revisit
one of our crash course videos on the
fantastic beasts franchise so that's it
I'm Riley and this has been another
video on Collider quick
[Music]